foreign
Bobby Lee remember Bobby Lee remember
Bobby
yeah a little Asian man so he went on
another guy who looks like an Asian
man's podcast Bobby Kelly and uh Bob by
the way shout out to Bobby Kelly's lost
a lot of weight I heard you'll see
you'll see related to the drama was it
too lazy brother and brother look at me
well my brother just did not quite old
skinny because all you did when I did a
show with him back in the day yeah he
was really that was Comedy Central
skinny boy but he's getting [__] good
for him all again for him
he did he comes up this week oh great
yeah and it's the funniest episode we've
done he's talking about his brother
going on a show it's great but this one
with my brother is wild okay it comes
out this week and
um and my brother won't be on tigerbelly
for a while why I can't get into it
really you'll see yeah did he hit you no
I love him very much did you fight
you [__] whoever the guy that asked the
question yeah is trying to strip
problems really yeah wow I don't like
people who stir problems so there's like
a super chat that was sent in like of
course next question
so you got in a fight with your brother
no I love my brother go ahead but you
get into a fight I don't know see this
is why thank you by the way Bobby Kelly
I like everybody okay I wonder why the
rattle comes out I won't I won't the
rattle if you ask me again the rattle I
won't ask you that again all right oh no
you guys are good not the rattle so I
think most people probably assumed we'd
never see Bobby's brother on tigerbelly
again because him and Kyla obviously
have some problems with each other I
think during all that bread and Shop
stuff or maybe even before that sometime
around then there's some DMS that were
leaked from Bobby's brother to some girl
I think yes where he's talking about how
cloud is bad for him she might be using
him and he magically broken up ask him
about up last year and for that next
question all right uh sane Z rage says
ask him about uh Brendan Schwab and
Brian Callum sending him see there we go
they threaten you I mean it's just like
you just like the stroke buddy I'm not
asking these people dude let me ask you
a question do I know the questions
before they come in no I just have them
in front of me okay I don't know why
they threaten you because you you now
you're opening up I mean think about the
refrigerator can you cover your stomach
all right so what you're opening up a
window oh
this thing yeah yeah I love Bobby Kelly
so very much yeah it's
oh let me say something why would they
threaten you that there's a macho big
guys that it really could hurt somebody
why would they threaten you oh man it's
such a big thing man just tell me the
little version there is no little
version what did you do
[Laughter]
what happened what was your part of it
there is no part you didn't they just
threaten you let's beat up Bobby because
if I were to even get into it right now
it's gonna start the war again and it's
died down okay so they don't really want
to hurt you no I don't think Bobby needs
to worry about this starting back up
again I mean I think Brandon just wants
to forget about it obviously I mean he
wanted to forget about it right after it
happened and now he has bigger problems
to deal with like Mark Harley you know I
don't think he cares about what Bobby
Lee is saying but also if Bobby Kelly
hasn't been following this at all it is
a lot to get into to explain everything
so I understand that but Bobby Lee
shouldn't have to worry about Running
Shop retaliating because he talked about
it on some podcasts at this point
Brendan's got bigger things to worry
about okay so they don't really want to
hurt you no I just have to say this is
that my relationship with those two guys
are pretty much done really yes I
thought you were friends with him no oh
no that stinks it's getting easier but
remember
Brian Callan was like I really hope I
could be Bobby's friend again I just
want to hug him and I want to kiss him
and make out with him and let's suck his
dick suck his [__] his brother used to
do you mean I think because Brendan
cousin okay sorry texted me the other
day the one who [__] the brother was
his former
um
wife were they married
[Music]
[Applause]
once you [__] your Brothers cousins are
nothing that's nothing it doesn't matter
this deal is broken who cares
at that point [__] all the cousins you
want it's not your brother
just saying
what was it watch your back no he's like
I have a job thing for you oh cool and I
go nah and that was pretty much it oh
really yeah he had a job for you and you
said no it was like an ad thing or
whatever an opportunity for me but I was
just like nah I'm not interested was it
good money it was okay was it for a
product you didn't like oh [__] oh yeah
I just right now I'm not uh ready to do
business with them really yeah okay so
serious very serious wow and very ugly
and it um
you know it had to do with my breakup
with kalila oh sure they did it they
broke you up there it is they did it
they were no I'm gonna disagree and I'm
not defending shop and I am not
defending Brian Callan I'm not defending
these people
what ruined the relationship was you
were dating a [__] sociopath
narcissist psycho I still leans
motorcycle
I disagree on the level but okay fine
fair enough but in there somewhere on
the Spectrum how's that okay of the [__]
craziness that's the reason personality
or Auntie whatever the [__] it is
anti-Semitism
anti-Semitism personality disorder
yeah and um wait that's a pro that's a
disease
[__] in five years it will be and the
ADL is the cure
you broke Aria Cobra yeah was it like
that
if you're not familiar with that
situation with Ari I made a video
talking about a while back you'd check
out but I just think it's funny that
Bobby's saying that Brandon and Brian
are responsible for his breakup with
kalila which you know there probably is
some truth to that because they broke up
right after all this drama went down and
also I'm pretty sure Brendan Brown no
featured front page of Rumble we got 5K
watch and do us a favor guys if you're
new here up fingers uh subscribe and uh
give us a like on the video all right if
you like what we're doing
we really do appreciate the new fans and
we're using the gold digger rumors and
the Hawaii stuff as blackmail against
Bobby and clylla because obviously they
thought they were running the fight and
the kids so I brought it and I don't
think Brandon and Brian ever really went
public with that information or like did
anything with it like they just used it
to threaten Bobby but then kalila
admitted it on the H3 podcast like she
admitted she was going to Hawaii every
weekend to see some guy yeah again look
I'm not saying the calendar didn't
expediate the process but it didn't seem
like they were having a good
relationship up until that point you
know bro the reason kalila broke up with
Bobby was because she realized she
didn't have to [__] him or pretend to
like him anymore and she could still get
all the benefits yeah yeah she's like a
parasite she's like a parasite that now
can control the host remotely and
there's no sense on living inside that
[__] host anymore why not move on to
another house